bien ce soir 15 nominations le record du
nombre de nominations pour un film aux
césars ça va ah bah ouais on est content
alors ça peut être totalement vous
pouvez vous la péter grave la société
octobre les mains je rappelle que c'est
un record
alors c'est assez marrant de faire la
soirée ici alors que un petit peu plus
bas là bas c'était le les boulevards des
théâtres que l'on voit dans la dans le
film avec ce passage absolument
magnifique ccc un musée c'est un film
extrêmement pertinent en fait c'est un
film très très en phase avec les temps
convient vous trouvez pas oui oui ça
dénonce plein de choses de notre époque
la naissance du capitalisme
suprématie de l'argent que l'argent
décide de tout même des sentiments
humains
annoncé un film qui résonne beaucoup et
votre personnage vincent c'est un
mélange de cynisme de talent de charme
vous fait ça bien ça donne surtout si
nice que non mais non ben c'était pas
tous les personnages qui étaient déjà
dans le livre super mais je trouve que
vous avez gendler ajouté un quelque
chose de chez pas de qui fait partie de
son cinéma en fait des personnages qui
sont toujours un peu
ouais une forme de cynisme dans une
forme de ce flamboyant ce que je trouve
génial
quand même complètement en marche à fond
une dernière chose si je me trompe pas
huit nominations cinq nominations ça
fait treize nominations devant moi c'est
ça et quand on reçoit le coup terrible
pour la nomination du dernier film on
est aussi content si on écoute ah ouais
bah on est toujours content
bon ben alors j'ai plus qu'une chose à
vous dire pour ce soir
merci beaucoup merci bonne s'arrête